hey guys it's max in front of me I have
two of Apple's brand-new laptops we have
the 2020 MacBook Air that was released
about a month ago and Apple just updated
their MacBook Pros unfortunately there
was no redesign it looks identical as it
did in the past but we have some changes
now so we did this video a month ago but
in that video we actually use the i-5
MacBook Air and so this time around we
have the i3 the base model the one that
we now recommend will let you know why
in just a bit and in this video we're
not only going to be covering the
displays keyboards performance we're
going to cover a lot more with some
surprises that you guys probably don't
know about so let's go ahead and get
started we're gonna start out with the
exteriors and you guys might notice that
these look so similar you really can't
tell them apart we're gonna keep the
MacBook Air on the left-hand side one
big change for 2020 is that both these
laptops now come with magic keyboards so
the magic keyboards they've got rid of
the butterfly keys that have very low
travel they weren't that reliable we
have more key travel now the keyboard
feels great a lot of people bought
MacBook Airs because this keyboard now
we have that with the MacBook Pro as
well now above these keyboards you guys
do notice that we have a touch bar on
the MacBook Pro some people like them
your little icons can switch depending
on what applications you have open but
other people really don't like them
thankfully our skate key is separate now
and then our fingerprint touch ID sensor
is on the side so those changes are nice
but you get that the MacBook Pro with
the air if you want to avoid that you
don't have to deal with it below our
touch pads are pretty much the same in
looking at it from the open position
they look very similar but there is one
difference the MacBook Air has its
iconic wedge shape where it gets very
thin at the bottom here and that means
that for long typing sessions you don't
end up getting you know literate
pressure on your wrists from this boxy
slate design of the MacBook Pro it's
just a little bit more comfortable
there's a couple more minor differences
Mac Pro's trackpad is actually just
slightly larger but not enough to notice
and then as far as weight the new
MacBook Pro is 3.1 pounds compared to
2.8 both got a little bit thicker a
little bit heavier because of the
keyboards but it's also hard to tell a
difference there and both of these for
the base model MacBook Pros they have
two Thunderbolt three ports on the
left-hand side and a headphone jack and
now let's talk about the displays both
of these are thirteen point three inches
they use Apple's retina displays we have
just over four million pixels with a
sixteen by ten aspect ratio great
displays but we do have some differences
the first difference is brightness the
MacBook Air comes with the display
that's rated at 350 nits sometimes it
scores closer to 400 whereas the MacBook
Pro comes with a 500 nits brightness
display that means it is noticeably
brighter especially if you're outdoors
where there's lots of reflections or in
a bright room if you work in those kind
of scenarios often the macro Pro is
definitely ahead and there's also a
difference in color accuracy if we take
a look at this box you'll see that the
MacBook Air just has a solid color
whereas the MacBook Pro you see the
circle you see the logo inside that's
because the MacBook Air doesn't support
P 3 wide colors and this shade literally
cannot be displayed on the MacBook Air
screen now that doesn't mean that the
MacBook Air is inaccurate for most
people it's fine but the MacBook Pro can
help show about 25 percent more colors
and that is great if you're doing raw
photo editing you're doing video editing
and things like that now both of these
MacBooks feature 720p webcams this is
the microphone and webcam quality from
the 2020 13-inch MacBook Pro and this is
the webcam and microphone quality from
the 2020 MacBook Air you guys let me
know if you noticed any differences in
terms of microphone or video quality
down in the comment section and now it's
time to compare the speakers go ahead
and put on your best pair of headphones
and let's take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that was very interesting let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section but I definitely noticed a
couple differences first off the MacBook
Pro does sound better as richer deeper
bass maybe more full mids sounds more
balanced but it's quieter and that's
weird because if you guys saw our
previous comparison the MacBook Pro was
louder than the MacBook Air but not
anymore so I don't know if they took the
2020s and they made the speakers a
little bit quieter overall just so it
sounds better like they do the 16 inch
MacBook Pros or maybe there's a variance
in machines but this time around the
MacBook Air doesn't sound as good but it
definitely is louder let's start getting
into performance starting off with SSDs
both have 256 gig SSDs even though they
have the same size SSDs the MacBook Pros
are faster the MacBook Air got just
under 800 779 right compared to 1,100
and on the reed and got 1,100 almost
1,200 compared to 1600 so the capacities
being the same doesn't mean that the
speeds are the same and now let's take a
look at CPU performance
I have Geekbench 5 open right here I'm
gonna go ahead and hit run and both
these machines with their base back come
with eight gigs of ram which is great
but only the MacBook Air features
Intel's latest 10 generation processors
the one in this machine is an i3
dual-core but I'll also give you
performance numbers for the i-5
quad-core which we tested previously
whereas the MacBook Pro even though this
is a 2020 we still have the same 1.4
gigahertz I 5 quad core that's an eighth
gen so it's multiple generations old now
Apple decided to stick with that if you
want a 10 gen CPU in the MacBook Pro you
have to spend at least $1,800 and we
have our results which are interesting
even though this MacBook Air is a dual
core i3 the single core performance is
actually almost 15% higher than the
quad-core MacBook Pro that's because of
those 10 generation chips but if we look
at multi-core our MacBook Pro with
gen quad-core processor that actually
gets about 80% higher performance now of
course we are comparing a dual-core
against a quad-core and with the MacBook
Air you could spend $100 more and you'll
get an i-5 quad-core just like this one
is but its attention but there we'll end
up getting about 3200 so we're still off
I'll explain exactly why that is in a
second but first let's take a look at
graphics I'm gonna go ahead and run the
metal test in Geekbench 5 and I do want
to let you know that this I 3 comes with
pretty good graphics g4 10th generation
Apple didn't use the cheapest until
graphics and the 8th gen chip and here
Apple use the better graphics as well
for that time so it's going to be
interesting seeing how they compare and
we have our results they are fairly
close but surprisingly the MacBook Pro
with its older graphics actually beats
out we have 6100 compared to 5700 now in
the past this MacBook Pros scored quite
a bit lower but I think it's just driver
optimizations or other improvements that
got the score up and the MacBook Air
always got these results with a g4
graphics but if you do spend a hundred
dollars extra on the i-5 that gets g7
graphics at that closer to the 1,800 our
MacBook Pro and then that will get about
9000 so a big improvement
now let's push the graphics even further
I have Unigine Heaven benchmark open
here this is a gaming benchmark it's
gonna put a big load on the graphics
chip and I've had it running for just a
little bit now and it's very interesting
to see the differences as far as fan
noise and temperatures the MacBook Air
has been at a hundred degrees pretty
much the whole time since I started it
and the fans are just now starting to
ramp up same thing with the MacBook Pro
except the macro car is at 91 degrees
overall for the CPU package and we're
running out 4000 rpm so let's give it a
little bit more time we'll see how they
compare and now we're nearing the end of
the test the macro pros fans spun up
it's at 83 degrees compared to these
fans also spun up a little bit quieter
though running out a hundred degrees
Celsius and here are the results we have
6.3 FP
yes on the air and 10.7 on the macro pro
not double but getting that it's a big
difference in performance and if you're
wondering about the i-5 with the g7
graphics that are better than these it
actually got 9.0 in our previous test
now the reason why we don't recommend
that is because of thermals and that's
why you got 9.0 instead of actually
beating the MacBook Pro out like it
should of now let's get into our thermal
comparison I'll show you guys a big
difference between these laptops
even though Apple updated both of these
laptops they didn't change anything with
the cooling systems the MacBook Pro the
base model still has a single fan where
the top-end model has dual fans you guys
should check out that comparison and the
MacBook Air has a fan but it does not
have a heat pipe connected to the CPU
when you're using these laptops they get
quite hot too the MacBook Airs do and
they tend to slow down as well which is
why we're seeing such a big difference
in performance and even the quad cores
aren't performing where they should be
performing so here's an example for you
guys here I have a 4k 60 video opened up
go ahead and play it on both here the
MacBook Air instantly shot up to a
hundred degrees Celsius our fans are
spinning up whereas the MacBook Pros at
65 degrees Celsius the fans are turned
off zero rpm completely turned off and
this is definitely a more extreme kind
of scenario let's go ahead and just
switch to 1080p 60 instead of 4k 60
iLike watching 4k cuz everything just
looks better even if your screen isn't
4k and here the MacBook Air is running
at 83 degrees Celsius 86 whereas the
MacBook Pro still at 64 this is Vienna's
off here fans running at 2700 rpm now
this is the i3 model this is the dual
core this is the one that we recommend
that's because we use the i-5 we had did
a bunch of tests and comparisons with it
and the i-5 will run sometimes ten to
fifteen degrees hotter without quad core
and then it runs even louder right now I
am downloading a game in the Epic Games
store and as the video is being
downloaded it's also being decompressed
or uncompressed and the MacBook Air
instantly went up to 100 degrees Celsius
and the fans are starting to spin up
this is even the dual core i3 and
compare it to the MacBook Pro we're
running at 70 degrees Celsius the fans
are spinning at the lowest speed
possible now this is a medium to heavier
task but a lot of different tasks like
this the MacBook Air will get it will
start to heat up and then the fans will
kick up and then they'll start to get a
little bit annoying I know a lot of you
guys commented and mentioned during zoom
calls the fan is running loud and it's
these medium kind of tasks that really
make me want to push people towards the
MacBook Pro now that we have the new
keyboard it's gonna stay cool it's gonna
stay silent for most things that you
throw at it whereas even the i3 with
these medium tasks it will heat up and
it'll start to get louder the i5 and i7
even louder so with the MacBook Air I
would suggest the i3 if you don't like
that fan noise and now finally let's put
an even bigger load on it and we'll see
the differences in temperatures and
frequencies and I'll also give you guys
the performance from the quad-core
options on the MacBook Air and tell you
guys why I don't recommend it we're
starting off the test here and as you
guys see the MacBook Air actually hit
about 18 watts only not that high
the MacBook Pro hit 40 watts just over
that's a big difference in wattage and
as far as the temps the MacBook Air
pretty much instantly hit a hundred
degrees Celsius the Mac Pro is about 85
a much slower more gradual curve as far
as temperatures and frequencies both are
staying up 2.7 3.0 and keep in mind this
is a quad core not a dual core and now
the MacBook Pro is about halfway done
maybe a little bit more so temperatures
are 95 degrees Celsius compared to 99
pretty much 100 on the macbook air is
running at 3 gigahertz quad core
compared to two point three 2.2
dual-core an interesting thing to note
is that the MacBook Air with the i5 quad
core we're running at about 1.5 right
now much lower frequencies because of
the heat the MacBook Pros using 25 watts
compared to just nine on the air and as
far as fee annoys the MacBook Pro is at
7,000 rpms now the fans are kick
up really high to be able to maintain
that 3.1 gigahertz quad-core boost clock
whereas the MacBook Air it's running at
5300 it's definitely quieter and that's
because we have the i3 when we tested
this with the i5 it also was very loud
and finally our results are finished
with the MacBook Air six hundred and
nineteen points compared to a thousand
five hundred and fifty six more than two
and a half times the performance for
three hundred dollars difference in base
price now of course you can get a quad
core tension with the MacBook Air that
actually got nine hundred and nineteen
points even though it has twice as many
cores so you guys could see the
difference in the thermal performance
having the extra Headroom even with the
less efficient older processor that
score is excellent and now it's time to
talk about prices in our final verdict
so we have a three hundred dollar price
difference between these two machines in
their base configurations but that
doesn't tell the whole story
sure our SSD is the same our base ram is
the same but if you're somebody likes to
have multiple programs open lots of tabs
you might want to go up to 16 gigs and
ram with the MacBook Air that costs you
$200 whereas with the MacBook Pro that
only costs you $100 and then if you want
a little bit more performance you don't
want the i3 dual core you want the i-5
for the better graphics and the CPU
that's another hundred bucks and then
we're getting closer and if you go for
the i7 which you absolutely shouldn't
get you're up to 14:49
and it gets more expensive than the
MacBook Pro at 1400 and even with the i7
that gives you 3500 Geekbench score
instead of almost 4000 so if you care
about performance whatsoever if you're
gonna be upgrading anything go for the
MacBook Pro it is worth it it's a better
value overall not only that you also get
a brighter screen that is more color
accurate as well and on top of that even
if you get the i3 model with the MacBook
Air the MacBook Pro is going to be
quieter and run cooler for a lot of the
tasks that you're going to be doing now
that doesn't mean the MacBook Air is
a green machine it definitely is but we
would just highly recommend if you're
buying one go for that $999 model even
better check out the links in the video
description there's often discounts with
some of the companies that we link out
to and that also helps to support the
channel so get the base model use it
you'll be happy as long as you don't
need to have good performance if you
care about performance I'd all go for
the MacBook Pro get that $1,300 spec
spend another hundred bucks if you want
16 gigs at RAM and you'll have a great
performing machine with a nice new
keyboard and definitely don't go for the
i7 for 300 bucks on this one either if
you're gonna spend more money upgrade
more stuff take a look at our video
where we compare against the 1800 r-spec
we'll have that linked right over there
there's a lot of small differences that
you would not expect thank you guys for
watching click that circle above to
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]